there's some singularity that you guys
are using the the way I've understood
that term correct me if I'm wrong is
that it's going to be the one innovation
or one invention that essentially
changes everything forever
well singularity isn't necessarily one
invention the singularity which is
coined by Kurt well it's coined by my
friend Vernor Vinge's who's not a guy
you should interview he's in San Diego -
brilliant guys down there but Vernor
Vinge is a cemetery down there
yeah Vernor Vinge he was a math
professor at a San Diego University
actually but well-known science fiction
writer his book fire upon the deep one
of the great science fiction books the
ing e Vernor Vinge e yeah brilliant guy
fire upon the DVR any further oh yeah
the ER no oh yeah oh yeah he's brilliant
he coined the term technological
singularity back in the 1980s really but
he he opted not to become a pundit about
it because he'd rather write more
science fiction that's interesting than
a science fiction author Ray Kurzweil
who's also a good friend of mine I mean
Ray Ray took that term and fleshed it
out and did a bunch of data analytics
trying to pinpoint like when it's gonna
when it would happen but the basic
concept of the technological singularity
is a point in time when technological
advance occurs so rapidly that to the
human mind it appears almost
instantaneously like imagine an 10 new
Nobel prize-winning discoveries every
second or something right so this is
similar to the concept of the
intelligence explosion that was posited
by the mathematician IJ good in 1965
what IJ good said then the year before I
was born was the first truly intelligent
machine will be the last invention that
humanity needs to make right right so
this is an intelligence explosion is
another term for basically the same
thing as a technological singularity but
it's not just about ai ai is just
probably the most powerful technology
driving it I mean there's AI
there's nanotechnology there's femto
technology which will be building things
from elementary particles I mean there's
life extension genetic engineering mind
uploading which is like reading the mind
out of your brain and putting putting it
into a machine
you know there's advanced energy
technologies so that all these different
things are expected to advance and
around the same time and they have many
ways to boost each other right because
the you know the better AI you have
you're a I can then invent new ways of
doing nanotech and biology but if you
invent amazing new nanotech and quantum
computing that can make your AI smarter
on the other hand if you if you could
crack how the human brain works and
genetic engineering to upgrade human
intelligence those smarter humans can
then make better AI eyes and none of
technology right so that there's some of
the virtuous cycles among these
different technologies the more you
advance in any of them the more you're
going to advance and in all of them and
it's a coming together of all of these
that's going to create you know radical
abundance and and the technological
singularity